well with me now is now Charvet a Labour
MP for Bradford West and the vice-chair
of the All Party Parliamentary Group on
social integration so let's talk about
it all very good to see you now sure I
mean you worked extensively in the
community in Bradford before you were
elected do you recognise the Bradford
that Louise Casey describes absolutely
there's lots in Louise Casias report
which I very much welcome in terms of
those pockets of patriarchal communities
patriarchal culture is very segregation
and there's not the the wrong thing
would be to dismiss Louise Casey's
report I think it's very welcome it's a
conversation that we need to have
nationally and however I do have some
concerns about the report and those are
that we I feel we've really missed an
opportunity and when we're talking about
integration what we've missed here is
here is a report when we've had which
and Louise rightfully touches on the
issues around white working-class people
not having and not having the same
opportunities to get to university etc
but actually we've not talked about
we've talked about extremism and friend
and that debate about extremism and
Muslims but we've not talked about
especially in the era post the murder of
my colleague Joe Cox
we've not touched on that and I think
that's will be a real missed opportunity
because integration is a two-way street
and it's not it's not just about what
about those communities that we have
left behind not just a Muslim can
suddenly do you think I mean you think
fears a factor that's why community
would bond together I say they let the
far right being left out I think I think
the the conversation about extremism
around the far right the rise of the
far-right about communities feeling out
of touch the working white working-class
communities we've missed about
conversation in this report I also feel
lost it makes very valid recommendations
and absolutely the government should be
implementing them it doesn't give it it
doesn't give us a solutions and the
narrative to actually take them
conversations further and for me that
the post especially known to have no
mention of one of the most significant
things that has happened and white
supremacist meat emerges a British MP on
our streets of Great Britain and yet it
doesn't get a fleeting mention I found
very disheartened by that so that's one
of the misses on
on your book what about poverty and of
course Louise Casey deals with the issue
but I mean is that could that be the the
deciding factor I mean you know she does
describe you know the levels of
unemployment within some of these
communities much higher than the general
rate and things like that I think if you
look at the Twitter handles today on
this report if you look at what people
are saying out there the op-eds that
have been put out there there is a huge
correlation and Louise rightfully points
the optional report in terms of poverty
so 25 percent of the Muslim community
live in 10% of those most deprived wards
and poverty and integration go hand in
hand so the issue of integration doesn't
affect the middle classes it doesn't
affect so the class issue hasn't been
talked about and let me go back to it
ultimately is this a real deflection of
government austerity policies because
where does the austerity fall it falls
on those that need more support that
needs interventions that need that
infrastructure support and Bradford West
where I come from my constituency fourth
most deprived constituency in the whole
UK you know that those statistics and if
you look at integration educational
attainments when we invited Louise we
invited Louise to Bradford and I spent
the whole day introducing her to you
know the bat for the Literature Festival
I took her to the mosque very madrasah
and Merkers we had a lot so we had a
really engaging discussion and it
started from the premise of Education
and I'm not convinced that that report
that's what I wanted to throw in there
because okay we've got the poverty angle
here but there's poverty impact upon the
the cultural in the misogyny the
patriarchy either the plight of some
women in these communities not leaving
their home it seems very often not even
learning English I think absolutely
Louise is absolutely right you want in
the isolde budget back that that should
have been cut in the first place I think
it's absolutely right but we need to
concentrate on education and I think
it's absolutely right that we do have
misogyny we do have patriarchy in
communities in cultures but that is not
exclusive just to Pakistani Muslim
communities and what this report also
misses is we have the concentration of
his reporters or Muslims of Bangladeshi
and Pakistani heritage
yet we those Bangladesh in Pakistani
communities only make up less than 50%
of a Muslim community in this country so
what about the rest of those communities
were about the black
communities were about the Irish
experience what about the Scottish
experience we've not got that so should
this report have been if we're talking
about a wider integration report or
should we be taught calling this report
to Pakistani and Bangladeshi port
because that doesn't even cover because
although Congress absolutely okay Nash
are very good to see thank you very much
indeed for your views